you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme the green gold rush
how lithium is crucial in the uk's
transition
to renewable energy we explain how
satellites are being used in the fight
against climate change
and the man on a mission to make insects
the food of the future
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and one of those solutions is
electrification but to effectively
reduce our fossil fuel emissions we need
to do it on a vast scale
and to use renewable energy rather than
coal and gas-fired power stations
electricity will need to be stored at
scale in batteries
so lithium the crucial ingredient for
batteries is vital to the green
energy transition so where is lithium
found and
mined well australia is currently at the
top of the list
then chile which is believed to have the
world's largest reserves
and then china before it's ready to be
taken to the electric car
that lithium needs to be processed so
it's not just enough to have natural
deposits
if you want to make batteries you need
the factory capacity too
and china dominates battery
manufacturing with 77
of the world's capacity in 2020.
europe not including the uk lags far
behind
now the uk is on neither of these charts
because despite having
large deposits of lithium we currently
import
everything from countries who do mine it
and build the batteries
these are holland reports from cornwall
cornwall's barren landscape has long
been mined
but never before has there been such
urgency for new
exploration to bear fruit
drilling deep underground into hard rock
they discovered lithium the key
component
for batteries for electric vehicles but
the uk
is desperately playing catch up the
pennies just recently dropped we are way
way behind
china china is a centrally planned
economy they've been planning this for
years
they can see the electric vehicles on
the horizon
they've locked up all the supply chain
they need and really that puts
europe and the uk at a significant
disadvantage
from boreholes they've also found
lithium in geothermal waters
in a porter cabin geologists showcased
their treasure
but mining and processing the metal on a
scale to meet the uk's needs
could be a decade away the test site
itself
is still under construction mining
companies are looking at the landscape
with fresh eyes it's not fossil fuels
that the world needs
but metals for green technologies
what lies beneath nobody knows for sure
but with the phasing out of petrol and
diesel cars
there are fears the supply of important
metals
may not match demand lisa holland sky
news
cornwall so how could the uk
use specialist materials like lithium to
create greener energy
well with me now is karen hudson edwards
professor in sustainable mining at the
university of
exeter welcome to you so what part
can lithium play in our push to cut down
on our carbon emissions
well anna you've really touched on it
already we really need
lithium to make lithium ion batteries
and these are rechargeable batteries
that can be used in electric cars
in our mobile phones in our laptops and
with the growing need to reduce our
carbon emissions we really need to be
producing
a lot more lithium to make these
batteries and make this technology
so what are the prospects for mining
lithium in this country without a cost
of the environment
i think they're very good actually so i
work down in cornwall
and we've seen a resurgence in
exploration we have
granite rock that underlies the whole of
cornwall
it's lithium bearing it's very special
granite
and several companies are exploring for
lithium
in the hard rock but also in the
geothermal fluids
and this can be done in a way that
doesn't harm the local
environment yes the prospects are
looking very good so the geothermal
lithium for example
the mining all you're going to do is
take the waters through a borehole
extract the lithium and then put the
water back in the borehole so there's no
waste
and in some of the hard rock deposits in
cornwall
you're going to be taking them from the
clays so you're going to have some waste
product but that waste can be reused for
other things
and for example a small company makes
bricks that contain holes that bees
can hibernate in karen hudson edwards
thank you
in today's other climate news
campaigners are warning against a shift
to hydrogen
to heat our homes unless it's made from
clean energy
environmental groups have jointly
written to the government criticizing it
for
investing in hydrogen production they
want ministers to commit to renewable
ways of making hydrogen
to help the uk move away from fossil
fuels
[Applause]
the united states climate envoy will
visit the uk in the next few days for
talks on enhancing global climate
ambition
ahead of the cop 26 summit in glasgow
john kerry is meeting government and
business leaders in italy today
he'll also head to germany on his
five-day trip
[Applause]
a study says the world has to replace
wheat maize and rice with kelp
maggots and algae to create
risk-resilient diets in the face of
climate change
researchers at cambridge university say
radical changes to the world's
food system will be needed in an era of
growing environmental threats
they say farming microorganisms such as
spirulina to create so-called future
foods
could help bring an end to global
malnutrition
now with less than six months to go
until the cop 26 climate summit its
president
has warned the world is still not on
track to limit global warming to 1.5
degrees
in a speech building up to the event in
glasgow alok sharma said human activity
is imperiling the planet if we do not
take this chance to keep 1.5 degrees
alive
it will slip from our grasp and so will
our best hope of building the future we
want
to see so cop 26
must be the moment that every country
and every part of society
embraces their responsibility to protect
our precious planet with me now is tom
rivet carnage who was the chief
political strategist for the paris
agreement
and co-founder of global optimism so
hello to you
alex sharma there stressing the
importance of cop 26
but there are some doubts that it can go
ahead in person
because of the pandemic how important is
that in person element do you think
could the paris agreement have been
struck
if the conference then had been virtual
or even semi-virtual
well it's a very good question and first
of all thank you for having me love the
show
um so i mean alex sharma clearly there
setting out a statement of intent that
he's going to do everything possible
to ensure that cop 26 can go ahead in
person
and if you listen to what he said it's
clear that he understands
the profound importance that people are
able to gather in person and
particularly he called out the fact that
it's the vulnerable countries that need
to come in particularly everyone needs
to come but the vulnerable countries
coming
being represented there in person
provides them with a platform to be on
the world stage
to advocate for these policies they're
going to be so fundamental for their
survival
now when everybody gets together in the
format of a cop
that jeopardy and that tension of an
in-person meeting the personal
relationships the late nights the
working together
there is something about the crucible of
that time spent together and the forging
of those relationships
towards that common outcome that i think
sometimes can
precipitate these breakthroughs well yes
and that moment
when the paris agreement was struck was
a moment of pure
joy in the hall amongst all those
gathered there
what would prompt that level of joy in
glasgow what does success
look like for cop26 there was a moment
of real tension when the gavel had to
come down and we needed unanimous
agreement
that we were all going to adopt the
paris agreement together and that's what
sparked that outpouring of joy
it was that real jeopardy that last
minute negotiation
now this year in glasgow it's a bit
different what success would look like
is each individual country coming back
to the table
under the paris agreement and making an
increased nationally determined
commitment
towards ensuring that we can keep 1.5
degrees on track so
it will be a bit different it's it's
unlikely that we will have that moment
of kind of
global togetherness of gaveling but it's
very important that we try to construct
that moment so
success really looks like getting our
emissions trajectory
back on track with 1.5 degrees thank you
scientists say earth observation
satellites are playing a vital role in
detecting
climate change the data generated from
the images is being used to monitor the
pace of global warming
and its impact across land and sea so
what can it tell us these are the eyes
on the planet
and we're going to have the most
detailed and comprehensive
view of how the surface of the earth the
atmosphere the oceans everything
all components of the earth system are
responding to
climate change different frequencies
that the satellite measures
have been combined to highlight certain
characteristics of the surface so the
reds here
actually represent vegetation cover the
vegetation we're looking at
is actually planted crops it's not the
tropical forest that once existed across
this
part of libya that crack is is going to
reach a second crack called halloween
crack and
a huge iceberg is going to form you
could put
london and new york or let's say london
and delhi
on that iceberg and you'd still have
room to spare
and when you're talking about sea level
rise it's not global mean that actually
matters it's what's happening at the
coast
next to london or los angeles or san
francisco or rio de janeiro these are
incredibly detailed um sophisticated
measurements
far more than you know if you like a
high resolution
now earlier we heard how scientists
think that eating insects could be key
to saving the planet well they're
already eaten by around two billion
people across the world
but many western countries struggle with
the concept
in today's climate diaries we hear from
francesco mageno who's on a mission to
make crickets
the food of the future
[Applause]
[Music]
gas plugs
but whatever animal-based protein
insects need
just a fraction of land water or feed
and they just emit a very few greenhouse
gases
to produce the same amount of protein
that's why they are very sustainable
and they are eaten as a traditional food
all around the world
problem is just in the west where we are
because we don't consider them as a
traditional food
and we are stopped by the yak factory
we started small giants because we
wanted to do
our bit to change the world we gave to
thousands of people the possibility to
change
their perception to us edible insects
and they are now considering them as
another kind of
healthy food
and that's it for today's show but you
can get your climate fix over the
weekend with our podcast
on this week's episode we're talking to
climate activist louisa
neubauer about how she took the german
government to court
and won that's on climatecast and it's
available wherever you normally get your
podcast from
and on our weekly digital show this week
we go behind the scenes of the world's
biggest wind turbine in blithe
that's available on sky news social
channels our app and our website
thanks for watching and see you next
week
[Music]